Heinrich ist bei uns Chefin der Grünen
Jugend sie waren nach diesem Kompromiss
diesem gefundenen recht unglücklich
müssen Sie nicht eigentlich total
dankbar sein dass die Atomkraft jetzt in
vier Monaten vorbei ist zu Ende ist
ja wir finden es auf jeden Fall sehr gut
dass die Debatte dann jetzt zum Ende
findet und dass ich auch die Debatte
rund um die Atomkraft endlich erledigt
hat weil wir jetzt seit Monaten eine
Scheindebatte um die Atomkraft am Bein
hatten während es eigentlich um ganz
andere Fragen ging der Grund warum wir
unglücklich waren es weil wir wieder das
Gefühl hatten dass naja wir reden über
Emsland so wirklich zur
Energiesicherheit trägt es nicht bei das
wissen alle und das ist eine sehr
faktenfreie Entscheidung war und so ein
naja ich glaube Timon hat dazu mal basta
Politik also der ganzen Situation gesagt
zwei Kollege genau mein Kollege und das
fanden wir dann schon irritierend und
ich habe mich schon gefragt wenn ich
jetzt auf die letzten Wochen und Monate
zurückschaue fallen mir andere Momente
ein wo man vielleicht eher ein bisschen
Richtlinienkompetenz gebraucht hätte
hätten wir zum Beispiel schon vor ein
paar Monaten wir wussten es ja schon da
entschieden dass es ein gaspreisdeckel
braucht dann müssen wir jetzt nicht
sagen oder dafür brauchen wir jetzt aber
noch ein paar Monate bis der dann wirkt
das heißt interessant dass wir vor allem
daran kritisiert haben interessant dass
sie sagen empfiehlt jetzt gegen Olaf
Scholz aber hat nicht auch Robert Habeck
mit dieser Diskussion um die leidige
gasumlage dafür gesorgt dass wir Monate
in Deutschland mit was ganz anderem
befasst war also als Grüne Jugend
Bundessprecherin muss ich ja Gott sei
Dank nicht hier sitzen um die gasumlage
zu verteidigen wir fangen von Anfang an
das ist die falsche Idee war waren da
auch sehr deutlich und sind sehr froh
dass sie jetzt abgeräumt wurde ich würde
sagen zur Wahrheit gehört dazu um sie
abräumen zu können hat die Aufnahme
neuer Schulden war die Aufnahme neuer
Schulden benötigt dagegen wurde sich zu
dem Zeitpunkt noch gestellt auch das
finde ich sehr faktenfrei vielleicht
hätte es Richtlinienkompetenz für die
Aussetzung der Schuldenbremse dann
einfach gebraucht oder für die
Aufnahmerichtlinien konnten es geht
natürlich auch nicht natürlich nicht
aber sie verstehen schon was ich meine
und das ist glaube ich das was mich
gerade so irritiert ich glaube wir haben
gerade sehr große Sorgen wenn wir auf
den Herbst und Winter schauen und dass
wir jetzt bei diesen wichtigen Fragen so
doll hinterherhängen das finde ich sehr
schlecht traurig Kevin Kühnert ist bei
uns der spd-generalsekretär ich gucke
gar nicht auf den Zettel jeder kennt
sagte mal wo ist die
Richtlinienkompetenz braucht da ist eine
Koalition am Ende der wusste Bescheid
naja da muss man sich ja vor Augen
führen was der Rahmen damals gewesen ist
das war eine große Koalition von zwei
quasi gleich starken Partnern hat
übrigens auch zu großen Konflikten in
der Union damals geführt und es gibt
nicht wenige die dabei dem jetzigen
Machtwort so heißt das nun von Olaf
Scholz sagen streng genommen hätte es
hier auch nicht einer
Richtlinienkompetenz bedürft denn die
beiden Protagonisten die da über Wochen
drum gerungen haben haben sie ja nun
beide am Ende gesagt sie können mit dem
Ergebnis gut leben das heißt hier musste
ja nicht einer mit einer dritten Meinung
auf den Platz treten um ein Konflikt
aufzulösen sondern hier musste glaube
ich einfach einer am Ende das
aussprechen was zwei andere vielleicht
vorher schon im Kompromiss sind im Kopf
hatten aber nicht aussprechen können und
am Sonntag schon gesagt haben und aus
Rücksichtnahme auf ihre Parteien
offensichtlich dann nicht ausgesprochen
haben oder den kleineren Weg des Übels
gehen wollten Jens Spahn ist bei uns
Vize der CDU weil sie sagen Herr Merz
sagt die FDP hat sich auch nicht
durchgesetzt und wer wenn wie sie auf
Christian Lindner setzte hat dann also
verloren wir müssen ja noch schon noch
mal schauen worum geht es hier
eigentlich es geht darum dass wir
ausreichend Energie haben für diesen
Winter und auch für den nächsten Winter
übrigens 23 24 der wird nach allgemeiner
Einschätzung noch schwieriger werden
weil wir die Gasspeicher nicht noch mal
wahrscheinlich werden so füllen können
es geht darum Blackouts zu vermeiden
sicher Energie zu haben und da finde ich
ist das Prinzip alles was in Deutschland
Energie produzieren kann Biogas Solar
aber eben auch Kohle und Kernkraftwerke
ans Netz und am Netz bleiben ist erstmal
ein sehr logisches und sehr vernünftiges
Prinzip und das darüber jetzt
tatsächlich seit fünf sechs Monaten so
ein erbitterter Streit geführt werden
muss mitten in dieser Krise das ist
nicht gut da geht viel Vertrauen
verloren das zeigen ja auch alle
Umfragen und jeder weiß ich habe es
gerade schon gesagt der übernächste
Winter wird halt noch schwieriger also
ja diese Kernkraftwerke müssten
eigentlich und ich bin sehr sicher die
Debatte wird auch kommen im Januar
Februar Schmerz sie müssten eigentlich
bis übernächstes Jahr Ende übernächsten
Jahres laufen das war es auch jeder und
die Entscheidung wenn nur eins noch
sagen zu der Richtlinienkompetenz weil
Franz Müntefering hat ja schon recht sie
sind ein richtiger Satz in dem Moment wo
ein Kanzler das nutzen muss ist eine
Koalition eigentlich deswegen am Ende
weil eine Koalition vertrauen braucht
und das ist ja keine Vertrauensbasis
mehr also in 16 Jahren Angela Merkel
hätte ist das nie gegeben im Umgang von
Koalitionspartnern miteinander dass das
so gemacht wird ich meine die nächste
Ausfahrt ist die Vertrauensfrage mehr
kann ja ein Kanzler nicht mehr machen um
den Laden zusammenzuhalten und dann auch
noch bei so einer vergleichsweise
kleineren Frage oder kleineren Lösung
genau genommen so mini-schrittchen das
sagt schon auch was über den Zustand der
Koalition mitten in einer schweren Krise
fragen wir die Journalistin am Tisch
Helene Bobrowski von der fatz der
Frankfurter Allgemeinen Zeitung ist das
was Olaf Scholz da machte ein Zeichen
der stärker oder ein Zeichen der
Schwäche naja es wäre auf jeden Fall
stärker gewesen
über dieses Machtwort nicht gebraucht
also hätte er Kraft seine Autorität im
Dialog eine Lösung gefunden und hätte
dieser Streit wer dieser dieser absurde
Streit um ein AKW dreieinhalb Monate
nicht so massiv eskaliert dass man das
Gefühl hatte es geht in dieser ganzen
Zeit gar nichts anderes voran so haben
es auch die die Koalitionspartner gesagt
der Knoten muss platzen damit wir in den
anderen Dingen Weiterkommen
genau und was ich interessant fand der
Kühnheit sie haben es gesagt herr Scholz
musste sich mit einer dritten Meinung
gar nicht einbringen das ist glaube ich
der Kern des Problems das ist auch das
haben übrigens FDP und Grüne
übereinstimmend gesagt man wusste bis
zum Ende nicht was Olaf Scholz
eigentlich will ja und
Richtlinienkompetenz bedeutet ja
eigentlich ich setze die Richtlinien
meiner Politik durch und versuche nicht
in einem völlig verfahrenen Streit von
zwei Positionen irgendeinen Mittelweg zu
finden also diese Debatte war auch
deswegen so verfahren weil der Kanzler
eigentlich nicht geführt hat und nicht
gesagt hat wie es laufen soll dann hätte
man diesen wirklich kleinen also kleinst
ja also ich meine das ganze Problem ist
ein ist ein großes aber diese kleine
Frage 1 2 3 AKWs drei Monate dreieinhalb
Monate oder oder ein Jahr länger ist
nicht das Problem dass dieses Land jetzt
primär lösen muss das hätte man viel
früher und viel schneller abräumen
müssen und es ist eigentlich also da bin
ich bei Herrn Spahn das verheißt nichts
Gutes über das Vertrauen unter den
Koalitionspartnern nach innen und und
auch jetzt bei Frau Heinrich sie sagt
der Streit ist jetzt beendet bei der FDP
die jetzt ja heute hier nicht am Tisch
sitzt aber hört man ja schon an Klänge
dass es möglicherweise dann im April
wieder aufgemacht wird oder vorher im
Januar also es gibt ja bisher noch auf
der Ebene von Andeutungen aber die
beiden anderen Partner so verstehe ich
das trauen dem Frieden auch noch nicht
so ganz dass das Thema wirklich vorbei
ist fragen wir noch mal bei der SPD nach
Kühnert hat der Kanzler die beiden
Minister damit blamiert oder hat er sie
erlöst
also ich fand das jetzt schon
ehrlicherweise etwas verwegener
Einschätzung das quasi die
Koalitionspartner sich Wünschen zu hören
wo Olaf Scholz steht damit es dann so
gemacht wird so würde ich mir das als
spd-generalsekretär natürlich häufig
wünschen aber in der Realität ist es so
ja nicht und wo die SPD in der Atomfrage
steht ist ja ganz klar das konnte man
unserem Wahlprogramm sehen das haben wir
in einem gemeinsamen Koalitionsvertrag
mit den Partnern dargelegt die SPD ist
auch Teil einer Bewegung immer gewesen
in dieser Gesellschaft die für ein
Ausstieg aus dieser
hochrisikotechnologie wo wir kein
Endlager und so weiter haben steht daran
hat sich auch überhaupt nichts geändert
wir haben in der aktuellen Notsituation
mit den Partnern zusammen eine
Kommission damit beauftragt einen
Stresstest und dann einen noch mal
verschärften Stresstest zu machen nicht
nochmal dabei ist rausgekommen dass das
sinnvoll sein könnte und so wird es
jetzt auch gemacht wirft aber unsere
grundsatzposition nicht um die ist da
ganz klar und das gilt vom Bundeskanzler
bis in die Partei unendlich viel
Vertrauen entschuldigt und wir sind
einfach so lieb lassen den Chef des
bdiis zu Wort kommen heraus vom großer
Schritt für die Grünen haben wir
verstanden vielleicht auch ein großer
Schritt für die SPD in dieser Frage was
man noch mal hinterfragen könnte
aber
95% Aufmerksamkeit für fünf Prozent
unserer Energieversorgung über vier
Monate sagen sie da auch ihnen fehlt es
Verständnis also es ist gut dass die
Frage jetzt abgeräumt ist und darüber ob
was sie im März noch mal diskutieren
müssen sollten wir nicht spekulieren
denn die Frage wie dieser Winter läuft
und mit welchem Füllstand der Speicher
wir aus dieser Heizperiode rausgehen
hängt von so vielen Faktoren ab für die
keiner eine Glaskugel hat
die Bundesnetzagentur Klaus Müller
bringt das ganz genau auf den Punkt wo
die offenen Flanken sind und deswegen
macht es für mich jetzt keinen Sinn
darüber zu spekulieren das werden wir
alle
sagen was eigentlich die wichtigeren
Fragen sind heraus
und die die Frage ist ja was wir aus
diesem Geschäftsmodell des Landes des
Industrielandes Deutschland für die
Zukunft machen weil eines wissen wir so
günstig an Energie wie wir das die
letzten Jahrzehnte alle miteinander auch
volkswirtschaftlich gekommen sind werden
wir nicht mehr kommen also damit ändert
sich etwas für die Grundfesten dieses
Industrielandes für unsere
internationale Wettbewerbsfähigkeit und
darüber müssen wir reden das ist sicher
wie viel Gas in den speichern ist ist
offen aber die Frage dass wir in einem
anderen Rahmenbedingungen erfolgreich
sein müssen als deutsche Gesellschaft
die ist sehr sicher und damit ist klar
dass es nicht nur um die nächsten vier
Monate geht sondern um noch viel mehr
und damit sind wir auch beim Thema
unserer Sendung und das geht tiefer und
betrifft jeden um nicht zu sagen jeden
in diesem Land und auch das Herz der
deutschen Wirtschaft
[Musik]
hossa es geht bergab mit Deutschland die
Zeichen sind unübersehbar diesmal
scheint German Angst ausnahmsweise
berechtigt Energie zu importieren zu
höheren Preisen bedeutet ja dass wir ein
Stück gewissermaßen ärmer werden dann
reden wir über schwere Schädigungen des
gewerkschaftlichen Kreislaufs über
Arbeitslosigkeit über große
gesellschaftliche Schäden was das für
das ökonomische Modell unseres Landes
bedeutet wir werden dadurch
ärmer werden wieso weshalb warum
ausgerechnet wir
Industriemotor Europas Exportweltmeister
fiskalpolitischer Musterschüler kommen
schlechter durch die Krise ungefähr 23
Prozent der Bruttowertschöpfung ist
Industrie es gibt kein Land auf diesem
Globus was so viel hat die haben die
Franzosen haben 13 die Engländer haben
zehn ja gerade weil weil unsere
Industrie so viel Energie braucht
unterbrochene Lieferketten uns viel
stärker treffen und weil wir aus allen
Energien aussteigen wollten bevor wir in
neue richtig eingestiegen sind
für eine Exportnation im globalen
Wettbewerb ein wohlstandskiller das
nächste Jahr sind wir dann mit minus 0,4
Prozent also einem negativen Wachstum in
einer Rezession
ein Gast dieser Sendung war noch nicht
dran und sie werden gleich verstehen
warum weil er uns jetzt erklärt Gabriel
Felbermayer nämlich der Chef desivivo
des Wirtschaftsforschungsinstituts
Österreichs warum es uns sogar noch
heftiger treffen könnte wenn man auf die
Kaufkraft schaut vielen Dank die 0,4%
gerade angesprochen wurden nicht
wirklich reflektieren dass die
importierten Preise das Problem sind
nicht die im Inland gemachten das taucht
im Verbraucherpreisindex auf das ist
Inflation die wir messen das wird aber
nicht bei der Berechnung des sogenannten
realen BIPs von dem die Rede war
berücksichtigt und wenn man das tut und
fragt was kann man sich mit den
Einkommen die in Deutschland
erwirtschaftet werden leisten dann sieht
man dass sich das jetzt nicht mehr so
ausgeht wie früher und nicht nur 0,4%
kleiner ist sondern eher um drei vier
Prozent um drei oder vier Prozent und
würden Sie sagen das ist für das Jahr
2023 zu sagen und danach kann es
aufwärts gehen oder ist das eine tiefere
Krise also ist das ein Abschwung oder
ist es ein Absturz
ich würde mir nicht dass die Situation
sich wieder verbessern wird einfach
deswegen weil diese großen
Preissteigerungen jetzt zu großen
Stücken hinter uns liegen auf den Erdöl
Märkten sieht man das beim Erdgas auch
die Preise gehen wieder zurück aber das
ist ein niveaueffekt das was jetzt
verloren geht das kommt nicht mehr
wieder es kommen wieder Jahre mit
Wachstum das ist klar aber dieser diese
Reduktion des Wohlstands der wird
Deutschland lange erhalten bleiben und
das hat auch etwas damit zu tun dass wir
im Grunde als ein internationaler Player
als eine Exportnation
überall in der Welt auch Einschränkungen
dieser Internationalität erleben oder
wie würden sie das Interpretieren also
wenn man jetzt auch die Handelskriege
damals noch unter Trump anschaut wenn
man Sanktionen vielleicht gegen China
diesen Ukraine Krieg anschaut wir haben
ja einen echten Bruch auch in unserem
Welthandel es ist ein Stück weit der
perfekte Sturm nicht die Industrienation
deutschland braucht mehr Energie als
andere das ist so und weil in der
Industrie Output natürlich auch stark
international gehandelt wird anders als
das bei Dienstleistungen der Fall ist
trifft der zunehmende Protektionismus
Deutschland auch stärker als andere
Länder und das sieht man schon viel
früher als erst jetzt nicht also diese
Problematik in der Industrie hat 2017
wahrscheinlich schon eingesetzt wer war
damals im Weißen Haus zu Hause und hat
Protektionismus gepredigt Donald Trump
das ist schon auch Teil des deutschen
Problems und man kann auch noch über die
Demografie sprechen über den Zustand der
Infrastruktur viele andere Themen über
der Steuern Abgabensystem das sind schon
einige Dinge zusammengekommen die den
großen riesen Deutschland zurzeit am
Boden halten fragen wir Sie auch noch
mal nach ihrem Eindruck oder besser
gesagt ihrem Wissen das ist ja eben
nicht nur ein Eindruck da gehen jetzt
wahrscheinlich bis zu 300 Milliarden
Euro an stützpaketen und an
Rettungspaketen an die und an die
Wirtschaft wird das in der Wirtschaft
denken sie gerade zum Überleben reichen
dann jetzt bin ich kein volkswerter
darüber Meier aber ich auf meinem
Bierdeckel stehen ein paar andere zahlen
weil die 300 Millionen die bleiben in
unserer Volkswirtschaft aber wir haben
ein paar andere Aufwendungen da werden
wir zahlen müssen weil wir Dinge von
außen brauchen weil wir teure Energie
Einkaufen das heißt wir müssen schon wir
wollen die Kasse schauen feststellen das
Land
zahlt mehr für Dinge
wir haben gelernt dass wir unsere
Sicherheit unter investiert hatten also
das Meer an Ausgaben für Verteidigung
müssen wir irgendwie zahlen wir müssen
die Transformation schaffen hin zum
klimaneutralen Land und haben mal
abgeschätzt was uns das kostet
dreistellige Milliardenbeträge um nur
die 2030er Ziele zu erreichen nebenbei
müssen wir uns für Naturkatastrophen
vorbereiten weil Mutter Erden langsames
System ist also selbst wenn wir morgen
kein einziges Gram CO2 mehr ausstoßen
werden wir mit Überflutungen leben
müssen also auch da investieren müssen
also auf unserer Ausgabenliste als Land
stehen die ganze Menge großer Posten und
die einzige Chance dann mit umzugehen
ist dass wir auf der Einnahmeseite alles
tun sollten um das unsassen zu können
Frau pobrowski Christian Lindner hat es
ausgesprochen Robert Habeck hat es
interessanterweise ausgesprochen dass
wir ärmer werden werden das ist einen
echten Wohlstandsverlust geben wird in
diesem Land fällt das dem Bundeskanzler
schwerer fällt es einem Sozialdemokraten
schwerer finden Sie gut kommuniziert
dass wir in einer viel tieferen Krise
sind als eben in einer jetzt
Energiepreis ja ich finde das gehört
tatsächlich zu auch ehrlich gesagt zur
Zeitenwende dazu ja also dass das nicht
nur wir jetzt bestimmte Maßnahmen
ergreifen müssen Bundeswehr und und und
entlastungspakete sondern das ist auch
ein Umdenken insgesamt gegen muss zur
Frage was bedeutet eigentlich
Solidarität und Solidarität heißt halt
nicht Nulltarif und endet nicht da wo es
uns anfängt weh zu tun sondern beginnt
im Grunde genommen da wo es uns wehtut
so und das dass das als Gesellschaft
getragen wird und das kann natürlich
nicht von allen gleichermaßen getragen
werden es gibt Leute die das nicht
tragen können den muss man helfen aber
das an das an sich das Ganze nicht
spurlos an uns vorübergeht sondern
müssen wir uns als Gesellschaft
entschieden haben und natürlich nicht
nur das nicht nur unsere Entscheidung es
gibt natürlich lauter Effekte die wir
nicht beeinflussen können aber dass wir
in dieser Lage sind da gehört es glaube
ich zur redlichen Politik dazu dass auch
auszusprechen Robert Habeck finde ich
hat es am stärksten ausgesprochen mit
auch seinen äußeren kriegste nicht Alter
und so weiter hat es immer mal wieder im
angedeutet Olaf Scholz hat tatsächlich
vor allem die Botschaft gesendet you
never walk alone also wir kümmern uns
und hat suggeriert also gut heute in der
Regierungserklärung hat da hat er das
auch ein bisschen anders konnotiert aber
vorher fand ich hatte im Grunde genommen
suggeriert dass der Staat sich um alles
kümmert und und das eine
Erwartungshaltung gibt wir sowieso schon
im Volk gibt dass man die Dinge
abpuffern kann und das sozusagen das ist
ja sowieso was finde ich relativ
deutsches wenn man irgendein Problem hat
fragt man sich wer zahlt eigentlich
dafür und im Zweifel ist es der Staat
also dieses dieses etatistische
Grundverständnis dass der Staat sich um
die Dinge kümmert und das ist natürlich
auch ein sozialdemokratisches denken sie
dass das so ist also ich glaube ich
kenne ehrlich gesagt keinen also wenn
bis jetzt sagen darf ich begegne ganz
vielen Menschen die echte Sorgen haben
und die jetzt wirklich noch vor allen
Aufrufen der Politik angefangen haben zu
sparen
also es ist so habe ich das nicht
gemeint ich habe nicht gemeint dass das
irgendwie Leute die die ernsthafte
Sorgen haben irgendwie
aufschreien und und so weiter sondern
natürlich die Leute das sehen wir ja
schon an den Einsparungen die es gibt
also die Leute heizen jetzt schon
weniger und so weiter das gibt es alles
und trotzdem gibt es in Deutschland
glaube ich insgesamt eine eine hohe
Erwartungshaltung an den gegenüber den
Staat okay dass der Staat sich um
bestimmte Dinge zu kümmern hat und dass
das Prinzip Eigenverantwortung nicht
nicht besonders groß geschrieben wird
und dass deswegen auch glaube ich
Politikern das verstehe ich auch damit
Zögern diese Botschaft zu selten zu sein
und zu sagen auch nicht gut ankommt es
wird richtig hart dann sind das jetzt
zwei Fragen an Kevin kühner die erste
lautet fällt es einem Sozialdemokraten
aus gewissen Gründen auch immer
besonders schwer zu sagen was da jetzt
auf uns zukommt das wird richtig schwer
und das wird richtig groß und wir werden
alle ärmer werden war also ist die erste
Frage was würden Sie sagen nein
Sozialdemokrat so wie der Bundeskanzler
spricht diesen Satz deshalb so nicht aus
weil er ein anderes Bild von unserer
Gesellschaft hat und das auch
richtigerweise diese Gesellschaft ist
die Summe von 84 Millionen Menschen und
nicht nur ein statistischer
Durchschnittswert wir müssen schon
präziser sein einfach nur zu sagen wir
alle werden uns nicht mehr so viel
leisten können wir müssen von unserem
hohen Ross runter und so weiter da muss
man sich doch klar machen da sitzen
Leute draußen zum Beispiel sechseinhalb
Millionen die jetzt gerade durch ein
Mindestlohn auf 12 Euro eine
Lohnerhöhung bekommen haben die sind
vielleicht seit Jahren nicht in Urlaub
gefahren die sitzen in der unisolierten
Wohnung auf 40 Quadratmetern und fragen
sich wo sitze ich eigentlich auf dem
hohen Ross von dem ich runterkommen soll
und schon sind wir mitten in der
verteilungsdiskussion richtigerweise
angekommen und die lautet dann nicht wer
bezahlt denn jetzt meine Probleme im
Alltag am Ende sondern der stellt schon
die Frage wer hat uns den strukturell
auch in Probleme in Abhängigkeiten als
Gesellschaft reingebracht wer verfügt
über die Möglichkeiten Transformation
unserer Wirtschaft voranzubringen und so
weiter und natürlich ist dann die
Antwort einfach jeder 20 Prozent weniger
so wie sich das jetzt manche beim
Energiesparen vorstellen keine
sachgemäße und adäquate Antwort die gilt
übrigens wenn ich das noch sagen darf in
die andere Richtung genauso einfach nur
jedem Industriebetrieb in Deutschland zu
rufen mach mal 20 Prozent weniger heißt
natürlich für ein energieintensiven
vorproduktehersteller im
Automobilbereich etwas ganz anderes als
für jemanden der irgendwie
obstportionen portioniert und zusammen
korreliert ja damit und da haben wir ja
auch die Probleme und trotzdem ist ja
die Frage kann man mit diesem
paternalistischen wir schaffen das macht
euch nicht sorgen you never walk alone
also schafft man es mit dieser Sprache
bei den Menschen wieder
Spuren gegangenes Vertrauen zu gewinnen
Herr Kühnert weil die Leute natürlich
sagen ich mache mir wahnsinnige sorgen
und du wirst mir bei Gott nicht bei
allem helfen können lieber Staat sondern
die Behauptung des Satzes you never walk
alone you never walk alone heißt nicht
wir bauen die ein Himmelbett und da
fallen alle auf Federn sondern niemand
wird allein gelassen und ich frage mich
schon also man kann ja den Satz jetzt
irgendwie als Fußball Champ Entlehnung
mehr oder weniger originell finden aber
was soll denn die Alternative als
Gesellschaftsmodell zu wir lassen
niemanden alleine in einer
Krisensituation die niemand von uns
schuldhaft herbeigeführt hat was soll
die Alternative denn da zu sein nach der
Wahrheit gewesen und der Aufrichtigkeit
zu sagen wie groß diese Krise sein wird
in der wir sind Herr Spahn auch der
Opposition fällt erstmal wenig weniger
ein als zu sagen wir müssen den Menschen
jetzt echt helfen und was kann man
eigentlich anderes machen als erstmal
schnell und damit ungerecht zu helfen da
sind wir klassisch bei diesem
gießkannten-prinzip
also zuerst einmal ist denke ich schon
eine Botschaft wichtig wir werden nicht
alle so stellen können als skeps diese
Krise nicht sondern wir werden und das
ist eine Verteilungsfrage schauen müssen
wer kann das tatsächlich alleine nicht
tragen und das sind viele bis weit in
die Mitte hinein Familie mit 2200 2500
Euro netto zwei drei Kinder Gasrechnung
vervierfacht sich die können das nicht
da geht doch nicht nur um Urlaub
streichen Zahlen der Bäcker der das
nicht zahlen kann und ich weiß halt bei
mir im münsterländischen Dorf in der
Bäcker zu macht der wird auch nie wieder
aufmachen bis im tint zur Industrie die
nicht wettbewerbsfähig ist in den USA
gibt es diese hohen Energiepreise nicht
in China und ich und deswegen geht es
darum da wo es eben nicht geht ohne
Unterstützung jetzt eine Brücke zu bauen
in diesem Winter aber da haben wir das
gleiche Problem wie bei der can-energie
vorhin bezüglich des Bundeskanzlers wir
wissen bis heute nicht was ist
eigentlich der Vorschlag der
Bundesregierung konkret mit was können
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger eigentlich
planen mit was kann die Industrie die
Wirtschaft planen für diesen Winter es
gibt einen Vorschlag der gaskommission
der ist mittlerweile fast zwei Wochen
alt eineinhalb jetzt über wahrscheinlich
am Wochenende dann zwei Wochen alt Herr
groß geworden war dabei und wir wissen
bis heute nicht auch heute nach der
Regierungserklärung nicht was wird die
Regierung umsetzen die einzige
Ankündigung war im März nach dem Winter
kommt dann wahrscheinlich der
gasgrundbedarf den wir schon vor sechs
Monaten übrigens diskutiert haben der
ist in der Umsetzung Komplex deswegen
dauert das aber hätte man halt vor drei
vier Monaten
hinzufügen darf muss natürlich sein was
wir doch erleben gerade chemische
Industrie energieintensive Industrie
keiner investiert gerade in Deutschland
also der zweite Schritt nach dem Winter
nach der Brücke ist ja die Frage welchen
Energiepreis welchen Gaspreis können wir
denn eigentlich in den Blick nehmen der
wird nicht so sein wie vorher aber wir
brauchen Planbarkeit damit auch
Investitionen in Deutschland es geht ja
um Arbeitsplätze stattfinden es gibt
übrigens um die Arbeitsplätze die unsere
sozialen Sicherungssysteme bezahlen es
sind gut bezahlte Arbeitsplätze in der
Chemieindustrie zum Beispiel von denen
der Wohlstand dieses Landes ziemlich
abhängt und deswegen gibt es zwei
Schulden es braucht zwei Paketen
Schulden machen wie viel Schulden machen
kann der Staat gerade etwas anderes tun
als Schulden zu machen und bei dem
schuldenpaket sagt die Opposition genau
aus diesem Grund nein
schuldenfinanzierung in dieser
dreifach-krise in der wir gerade sind
Nein zu schulden übrigens nein auch die
Schuldenbremse sagt ja nicht Nein zu
schulden schon gar nicht in einer
Rezession gibt es da Flexibilität was
wir sagen morgen soll abgestimmt werden
im Bundestag ein 200 Milliarden Blanco
wummsscheck
keiner weiß wofür also es haben so eine
Ahnung wofür aber ich weiß nicht also
ich kenne das halt so rum man redet erst
über das was man macht meinetwegen
gasgrundbedarf 12 Cent 80%
Vorjahresverbrauch konkreter Vorschlag
wenn die Regierung den macht kann man
ausrechnen was der kostet Industriepreis
sollen dann kommt eine Summe raus und
dann reden wir über die Finanzierung was
jetzt passiert ist wir werden oder nicht
wir der die Mehrheit die Ampel wird
morgen die 200 Milliarden beschließen
neue Schulden nein wir werden auch sagen
warum Herr Kühnert ich kann sagen warum
weil es kein blanko-check gibt wo man
ich weiß also es ist so wie man in der
Kneipe den Bierdeckel bezahlen bevor
überhaupt klar ist wie viel Bier
sind viel zu hoch angesetzt es braucht
die Volkswirtschaft im Moment beiden
weiß ob es zu hoch oder zu niedrig ist
weil keiner von uns weiß bisher heute
hat der Bundeskanzler eine
Regierungserklärung abgegeben und
trotzdem weiß niemand nichts genaues
nicht am was haben wir heute 20 Oktober
Heizperiode hat begonnen der Winter
steht vor der Tür die Leute rechnen
jeden Tag was sie noch zahlen müssen in
den nächsten Wochen und kriegen die
Frage klare Ansage und solange das nicht
da ist solange die Reihenfolge keine
andere ist werden wir nicht einfach ein
blank gecheck aushaltspolitischer
Sprecher Christian Haase danach frage
ich hat diesen
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds von
Herrn Lindner ausgesprochen gut geheißen
also Schulden zu machen und die in einen
solchen Sondertopf zu stecken stimmen
sie ihm dazu das Instrument als solches
das sagen wir morgen auch in einem
Antrag also wir erklären
hat dann noch mal lesen ein anderes
Instrument als solches erhalten wir für
ein mögliches ja kann man so machen aber
es muss halt die Reihenfolge Stimmen und
es muss erstmal da gelegt sein welches
Geld z.B eben durch Einsparung die
Koalition hat ja angekündigt sie will
auch einspannen im Haushalt was durch
Schwerpunktsetzung die Koalition macht
ja einfach so weiter Bürgergeld was auch
immer alle Projekte werden weitergemacht
als gab's keine Krise was durch
Schwerpunktsetzung auch eingespart
werden kann und wenn dann noch Schulden
mit dann kann es eben auch eine
Schuldenaufnahme geben aber man muss
doch andersrum anfangen muss doch erst
sagen was man macht und dann macht man
gegebenenfalls Schuld ich finde es
wirklich sehr gut dass die CDU gerade in
Zeiten der Opposition ihr soziales
Gewissen dann nach der langen groko Zeit
plötzlich wieder entdeckt hat ziemlich
soziale Veranstaltung naja ich glaube
das sieht man euch ja das sieht man
vielleicht mal so mal so und trotzdem
geht es mir ehrlich gesagt total auf die
Nerven wie das zu einem Partei
taktischen hin und her plötzlich wird
also jetzt zum Beispiel zu sagen auf der
einen Seite anzufangen und zu sagen ja
also es ist wirklich total wichtig dass
wir da sozialen Krise entgegenkommen und
jetzt wieder anfangen zu reden aber wo
kann man eigentlich noch einsparen
vielleicht beim Bürgergeld wo die
Menschen sich gerade vielleicht kann ich
drei Mahlzeiten mehr leisten können
vielleicht können wir ja noch gucken ob
man vielleicht noch bei den
Krankenkassen bisschen was einsparen
kann wo die Leute jetzt höhere Beiträge
bezahlen müssen das Einsparpotenzial für
viele Leute ist an der Stelle einfach
vorbei und deswegen finde ich das
wirklich komisch ich habe auch ein
Problem damit das nicht klar ist wieder
gaspreisdeckel aussieht da will ich mich
gar nicht einmischen dafür
ja und das kann ich ja auch kritisieren
an der Stelle aber dass sie jetzt quasi
die große sozialkeule an der Stelle
rausholen finde ich dann manchmal schon
ein bisschen irritierend wenn dann
gleichzeitig bei anderen Sozialmaßnahmen
wenn es dann wirklich um die geht wie
sie gerade selbst gesagt haben die es
wirklich nicht tragen können zum
Beispiel beim Bürgergeld dann doch
wieder ein bisschen dann doch wieder ein
bisschen wenig drin ist ich habe auch
meine Probleme mit der Art und Weise wie
das mit dem gaspreisdeckel Geschehen ist
mein allererstes Problem ist dass es
viel viel zu spät kommt also sich jetzt
anzuhören dass der gaspreisdeckel im
März kommt wir als Grüne Jugend fordern
auf jeden Fall dass es schon eine
rückwirkende Auszahlung dann für Januar
und Februar geben muss an der Stelle
eigentlich um zu ermöglichen dass
Menschen wirklich
niemals alleine durch diesen Winter
laufen denn das sind ja die teuren
Monate die wir alle erleben und dann
teile ich die Kritik an der Stelle total
und trotzdem irritiert es mich dass wir
dann wieder anfangen Arme gegen ärmere
auszuspielen in so einer Situation
naja man muss ja jetzt einfach das Geld
zur Verfügung haben vielleicht ganz kurz
zur Information für Hartz IV Bezug
werden die Heizkosten eins zu eins
übernommen und da wird ja auch
Heizkostenzuschuss hat der Bundestag
heute beschlossen das sind ja alles
Dinge ja aber wir müssen wir müssen sind
die Absicht trotzdem wir müssen aber
vielleicht mal in den Blick auf
diejenigen nehmen die nicht im
sozialbezug sind die irgendwie knapp
drüber liegen ich habe sie gerade
genannt 2000/200 2500 Euro netto haben
die jeden Tag arbeiten und die gerade
ihre Gasrechnung nicht bezahlen können
und die für ihn in die neu gar keinen
Fall die einfach nur eine Planung
brauchen und da sind wir uns ja
offenkundigen
so nicht noch einen tritt nach unten und
gegen dieses Bürgergeld
wir sind ja Felbermayer noch bei der
Frage ist das was die Regierung Scholz
hier tut etwas das in ihren Augen
Deutschland dann auch erst recht
überfordert weil es noch mal ganz viel
Geld in einen weiteren sondertropf ist
ist es schon das berühmte
Gießkannenprinzip das ja dann
offensichtlich die Österreicher auch
walten lassen weil sie haben
lustigerweise ab Dezember einen
energiegeld da gibt es einen Strom Geld
das die Leute schon kriegen und dann
monatlich kriegen genau wir haben eine
strompreisbremse die funktioniert
übrigens sehr ähnlich wie das was die
Kommission für Gas vorgeschlagen hat
also auch 80 Prozent und dann 20 oder es
wird nicht auf den tatsächlichen
Verbrauch des Vorjahres abgestellt
sondern auch ein Kontingent das ist
pauschalisiert insofern ist das in der
Tat ein bisschen mehr Gießkanne es geht
halt auch schneller es wird ab Dezember
gemacht und es hat den Vorteil dass man
darüber hinaus noch über einen
antragsweg über eine große Familie ist
noch weitere weitere Hilfen bekommen
kann ich glaube das ist schon notwend
dass die Menschen die unter den hohen
Preisen leiden dass die eine
Unterstützung bekommen ich glaube das
ist richtig wir müssen die Kaufkraft
Stützen es gibt auch andere Wege das zu
tun die Frage ist wie man das macht
damit die Preissignale gut ankommen wir
brauchen ja
einsparungsvolumina von 15 20 Prozent
über das nächste Jahr und ich glaube was
die folgende Vorschläge die da gemacht
werden die sind im Grunde was die
Haushalte angeht nicht schlecht wenn es
um die andere Hälfte geht die eher in
die Wirtschaft geht da
schaut das europäische Ausland schon mit
gewissen mit diesen Argon nach Berlin
auch Wien tut das wenn man fürchtet dass
da die Wettbewerbsverhältnisse in Europa
verzerrt werden kann dazu kommen wir
noch Herr Felbermayr ich will also auch
ob den deutschen wird davor geworfen aus
Europa besonders egoistisch unterwegs zu
sein auf der anderen Seite haben Sie mit
Ihrem Institut untersucht und das ist
ganz interessant mal zu zeigen wohin
sich eigentlich jetzt wird es noch mal
ein bisschen technisch aber ganz hoch
interessant wohin sich die
Bruttowertschöpfung innerhalb Europas
und auch gerechnet auch in Österreich im
Vergleich zu Deutschland und zu
Tschechien und zu der Schweiz entwickelt
wenn Sie hier einmal drauf gucken
Deutschland ist die rote Linie
da sehen wir relativ weit rechts am Rand
diesen Einbruch im Jahre 2020 das ist
Corona und sie sehen wohin sich die
Länder diese vier Länder dann
wirtschaftlich weiterentwickeln die
Schweiz ganz oben Österreich darunter
Tschechien ins Wachstum sich schieben
und Deutschland im Grunde genommen
zurückfällt fast bis auf dieses Jahr
das ist hochinteressant noch mal die
Frage womit ist das zu erklären dass wir
in dieser schlechten Ausgangspositionen
sind verglichen zu diesen drei Ländern
und sogar zu Tschechien also es ist
zumindest nicht mit der aktuellen
Energie große zu erklären denn die gab
es 2016/17 nicht als diese
wachstumsstelle sich auszubilden
begonnen hat es hat viel zu tun mit
großer Unsicherheit die glaube ich in
Deutschland schon länger da ist das hat
das mit der Energiewende zu tun wer
energieintensiv investiert muss ich ja
fragen woher kommt die Energie das war
erst lange Zeit eher unklar in
Deutschland es hat auch zu tun mit dem
in Deutschland früher einsetzenden
demografischen Problemen das werden alle
anderen Länder auch haben Deutschland
ein bisschen früher weil eine Fabrik
baut will dann ja auch die Beschäftigten
dafür finden das ist in Deutschland
nicht ganz so einfach wie anders so es
hat auch zu tun das muss man glaube ich
aller Ehrlichkeit halber auch sagen dass
in den Ländern die wir hier haben
Österreich zum Beispiel die Besteuerung
für Unternehmen abgesenkt wurde das
macht das Land attraktiver für
Investition attraktiver für die
Industrie das ist in Deutschland nicht
erfolgt und dann ist es sicherlich noch
ein Thema dass man ansprechen muss dass
die das Deutschland vom von der Struktur
der Industrie ja auch die Struktur der
Industrie noch mal anders ist nämlich
sehr viel Automotiv und Automobilsektor
der hat halt auch das sieht man in
diesen Zahlen ganz stark durch den
Strukturwandel weg vom Verbrenner wo
Deutschland Weltklasse war hin zu einem
Elektromotor den viele auch können da
hat die deutsche Industrie ein extra
Problem dass die Zulieferer die häufig
in Österreich oder in Tschechien sitzen
so nicht haben die liefern dann die
Autoteile ja vielleicht häufiger nicht
mehr nach Deutschland sondern in andere
Werke wo deutsche Hersteller ihre
Fabriken stehen haben und das sieht
glaube ich dieser ganze Mix aus Dingen
erklärt warum seit 2017 schon die
deutsche Industrie das ist nur die
Industrie die man da sieht nicht mehr
diesen Aufwärtstrend weiter fortsetzen
kann den sie seit 2009 eine Sorge vor
die Industrialisierung gibt
Herausforderung und das ist eine Sorge
die spricht auch der DGB aus und die
spricht auch Herr Kühnert aus weil wir
genau das befürchten müssen dass
Industrien sich einfach auch
verabschieden
aus Deutschland und in anderen Teilen
Europas oder aber der Welt ihre Zukunft
sehen das ist tatsächlich so und es
trifft nicht nur die großen Unternehmen
dort geht es leichter also wenn ich in
einem Gummi Konzern Standorte über die
Welt verteilt habe dann ist der Mix wo
produziere ich was und wie viel relativ
einfach zu machen was mich mehr ja
bedrückt hat ist wie viele
Familienunternehmer wie viele
Mittelständler inzwischen sagen hey bei
achtfachen Energiepreis und bei den
Steuervorteilen die ich in USA habe mit
einem bei American ich muss jetzt
ernsthaft planen ob ich meine neue
Maschine meine neue Investition nicht in
USA mache oder doch in Deutschland das
heißt die Unsicherheit von der sie
gesprochen haben die ist jetzt noch mal
starker geworden und selbst ich nenne
sie jetzt mal wahre Patrioten also
Mittelständler die bisher keinen
außerhalb Deutschlands hatten die
überlegen jetzt sehr ernsthaft und
planen wie müssen wir uns denn in der
Welt aufstellen und wenn wir diesen
Effekt in Menge haben in Deutschland
dann ist wirklich das Geschäftsmodell
dieses Landes in Gefahr und wenn wir
aber von den Europäern jetzt Egoismus
vorgeworfen bekommen dann sagen Sie auch
dass viel größere Problem ist die USA
also wenn ich mit wenn ich mit meinen
europäischen Kollegen Rede und denen
erklärt habe was wir da jetzt
vorgeschlagen haben an dieser Kommission
dann wird das ganz schnell ganz beruhigt
weil es sind nur ein Drittel also
weniger als ein Drittel dieses Geldes
klar war die Einschätzung hey jetzt
werfen die deutschen 200 Milliarden auf
ihre Industrie weil eineinhalb Jahre
also sind 25 Milliarden die für die
Industrie
vorgesehen sind auch andere europäische
Länder haben ihre Industrie gefordert
auch mit
Energiepreisen also der Aufruhr der
Europäer den höre ich zumindest von und
Kollegen und aus der Industrie nicht und
wenn sie noch mal sie sind in dieser
gaspreiskommission und danach wollte ich
sie unbedingt auch noch fragen
würden sie auch sagen dass unsere
Diskussion wie Sarah Lee Heinrich da
sowieso viel zu spät kommt Frage Nummer
eins ja ja man hat sie auch eher haben
können und würden sie zum zweiten sagen
dass wir mit diesen gedeckelten Preisen
oder mit unserem Vorschlag erst mal ein
Dezember Geld und dann im März mit
diesem 80-20 tatsächlich den Bürgern und
der Industrie helfen also erstens ich
bin fest davon überzeugt dass wir helfen
jetzt muss man ein paar Details spart
euch ein bisschen aus dem Nähkästchen
dieser Kommission den ersten Matz hat
sich ja keiner gewünscht aber bei den
Energieversorgern die
zahlungsmechanismen umzustellen für eine
zweistellige millionenanzahl von Zählern
das ist nichts was von heute auf morgen
passiert und da muss man einfach dann
den Versorgern auch glauben wenn würde
ich sagen okay wir schaffen das zum
ersten März was war aber auch klar es
muss früher eine Entlastung geben so ist
diese zweistufigkeit für die
Kleinverbraucher entstanden wir reden
über die Großverbraucher der Industrie
gleich noch mal anders aber für die
Kleinen Verbraucher ist es so entstanden
und weil uns auch klar war dass der
erste Matz zu spät ist ging es dann
darum und was ist denn die Brücke
dazwischen und über die Höhe der Brücke
kann man jetzt auch wieder länglich
streiten weil aber die Versorger in
ihren IT-Systemen arbeiten müssen wie
willst haben wir vorgeschlagen macht es
mit einer Zahlung man hätte natürlich
auch sagen können alle monatsabschläge
bis dahin reduzieren wir um x Prozent
wieder Praktikabilität es muss schnell
gehen möglichst schnell deswegen haben
wir das so gemacht diese
dezemberabschlag und der soll gleich für
drei Monate sein bei den Österreichern
glaube ich funktioniert das blendend
also ihr schafft das monatlich wir
wollen es bis Dezember umgesetzt haben
ob das so klappt wird man sehen und es
ist eine strompreisbremse Gas ist
so und dann fragen wir Kevin Kühnert
weil er hier für die SPD steht was wäre
denn ihr liebstes Modell Herr Kühnert
wie hoch muss dieses Geld sein was muss
da jetzt wenigstens für drei Monate
verstehen wir gerade also es gibt nicht
nur etwas für den Dezember sondern das
soll dann für Dezember Januar und
Februar helfen bis dann am 1 märz die
zweite Stufe gezogen wird was muss denn
da jetzt wenigstens ausgezahlt werden
für eine durchschnittliche Familie vier
Personen
das wird Ihnen jetzt keiner mit dem
spitzen Bleistift ausrechnen kann was
wichtig ist wenn wir beim Prinzipien
never walk alone bleiben ist es muss für
den Einzelfall immer funktionieren wer
keine Rücklagen hat braucht eine andere
Form von notfallunterstützung im Zweifel
als diejenigen die auch noch mal zwei
drei Monaten bis das greift
osnabrücklage bestreiten können so das
findet alles das wird heraus wo aus der
Kommissionsarbeit so wie wir aus der
politischen begleitarbeit bestätigen
können unter hohem Druck statt ist das
gerade alles oscar-preisverdächtig nein
hätte man mit allem auch noch zwei oder
drei Monate früher Abkommen anfangen
können ja ist mal interessant dass das
von denen kommt die vor sechs Monaten
als sie das angeblich diskutieren
wollten Herr Spahn selber noch beim
Thema Gas embargo waren also auf einem
ganz anderen sechs Monaten sagen
immer wie schnell sie die Bäumchen
wechseln mit ihren Forderungen wenn man
alles fordert ist natürlich auch
irgendwann mal ein Treffer mit dabei
also wir müssen uns einfach anschauen
dass wir eine hochvertrackte und
schwierige Situation haben ich fand das
schon bemerkenswert sie haben jetzt eben
gesagt den 200 Milliarden den stimmen
sie morgen nicht zu
einerseits kommt alles zu spät aber
andererseits wollen sie jetzt
anscheinend dass wir uns noch mehr Zeit
nehmen um ganz spitz auszurechnen was
das alles kostet wenn der Rußwurm wir
würden machen in Deutschland wird der
Sanke mich wir reden jetzt zu viel aber
Privathaushalte das viel abzufedern was
wir in der Industrie werden abfedern
müssen wenn wir nicht dem Irrtum
unterliegen man könne energieintensive
Industrie einfach mal in ein
Winterschlaf wie es sich manche wünschen
hineinversetzen da geht es nicht nur
darum ein bisschen den Preis abzusenken
wir werden so sicher wie das Armen der
Kirche spätestens Anfang nächstes Jahres
über ein industriestrompreis
beispielsweise in Deutschland da bin ich
fest von überzeugt zu sprechen haben
weil es hier um internationale
Konkurrenzfähigkeit geht wir haben
Unternehmen unter den vielen KMU's den
kleinen und mittelständischen
Deutschland die können ihre auflaufenden
zusätzlichen Energiekosten quasi gar
nicht weitergeben die produzieren
Komponenten mit denen stehen sie im
internationalen Vergleich in Konkurrenz
zu Leuten die zu niedrigeren
Energiepreisen produzieren wenn die das
weitergeben an den Abnehmer dieser
Vorprodukte dann sind die nicht mehr
Konkurrenz stehe ich auf dem Markt am
Ende also wir reden hier wirklich wenn
wir das ernst meinen mit dem Bekenntnis
unseren industriellen Kern zu wahren und
damit das was unseren Arbeitsmarkt
unsere Sozialsysteme Mitbestimmung
Tarifbindung Deutschland stark macht
wenn wir das ernst meinen dann werden
die 200 Milliarden wenn wir mit denen zu
rangekommen dann haben wir aber richtig
Glück gehabt am Ende aber ich frage was
kostet es denn wenn wir das nicht tun am
Ende was sind wir denn bereit an
volkswirtschaftlicher Substanz
preiszugeben wenn wir jetzt so ich muss
es wirklich so sagen so kleinkrämerisch
Anfang über diese Summen zu sprechen 200
Milliarden sind viel aber in der großen
Koalition hatten sie weniger Hemmungen
mit uns größere Pakete zu schnüren und
da hatten wir auch nicht vorher auf dem
Bierdeckel schon alles bis in auf den
Cent betrage aus deklariert wenn man für
was ausgegeben erst einmal dass die
Summe in der Größe also das ist nachher
in der Größenordnung sein kann
bestreitet doch auch niemand es geht
auch nicht um den Cent-Betrag aber wir
wissen nicht einmal sollen für die
privaten Haushalte 50 80 oder 100
Milliarden zur Verfügung gestellt werden
soll für das Thema die uniper Rettung
deswegen soll ja übrigens
indem Sie hoffentlich bald die
gaspreisbremse beschließen die
industriepreisbremse beschließen Juniper
meinetwegen beschließen in dem selben
Gesetz drin steht die Finanzierung
dann sehen die Dinge schon ganz anders
aus in dem Gesamtpaket kann man auch
dann einer Finanzierung zustimmobilien
von einer Opposition beim besten Willen
nicht erwarten dass wir ihnen einen
Blankoscheck rüberschieben in einer
Situation wo sie seit sechs Monaten sie
haben mit der gasumlage drei Monate
gebraucht dass man sich mal sie verliert
alles okay
was Sie vorhaben der
finanzierungssituationen Corona ist ein
gutes Stichwort es ist vielleicht sogar
mittlerweile so eine Art
Kriegswirtschaft weil der Staat
Kraftwerke Stützen muss weil er andere
Firmen Stützen muss weil er Stadtwerke
mit Liquiditätshilfen ausstatten muss
all das soll von diesen 300 Milliarden
ja mit bezahlt werden alles in allem man
könnte auch sagen der Staat ist in einer
echten Notsituation das ist das Argument
von Herrn Kühnert zu corona-zeiten
wurden 600 Milliarden raus ich sag nur
noch also erst einmal wir haben eine
angebotskrise die Preise sind so hoch
weil das Angebot knapp ist Gas wie Strom
erste Frage wer hat Strom ja beim vielen
Themen geht es doch erstmal darum das
Angebot zur hoch zu machen wie möglich
da sind wir wieder bei den Themen
Kernkraft Kohlekraft die immer noch
nicht alle am Netz sind was könnten das
würde schon mal helfen und übrigens auch
gerne länger als april und Preise zu
stabilisieren das zweite Thema ist
einsparen über einsparanreize wird im
Moment gar nicht diskutiert was ich für
einen Fehler halte kriegst du nicht
Alter das war ja damals Minister Habeck
zum Thema einspareinreize zu setzen wir
müssen aber auch einsparen und das
dritte sind eben diese Unterstützung die
wir besprechen ich sage noch einmal ob
das nachher 200 250 Milliarden Euro sind
weil da hat der Kühnert ja recht es geht
darum unseren industriellen Kern unseren
wohlstandskern auch nach dieser Krise
noch zu haben und der braucht diese
Unterstützung da haben wir überhaupt gar
kein Dissens es geht nicht um die Höhe
der Summe es geht um die nicht
Nachvollziehbarkeit diesen blank Defekt
der auch gar nicht nötig wäre man könnte
das im Verfahren zusammen machen wenn
man denn wollte wenn man wollte das
haben wir jetzt schon zweimal gehört und
sind bei Sarah Lee Heinrich pauli
Heinrich in Frankreich Frau Heinr Sarah
Lee ist der Vorname in Frankreich
protestiert man auf den Straßen und
nicht nur da hat der Staat schon
wesentlich mehr an die Bürger ausgezahlt
denken sie dass die Deutschen in
Anbetracht der Situation einfach noch zu
brav sind
ich weiß nicht ob zu brav die richtige
Kategorie dafür ist und ich glaube auch
Protest auch unabhängig davon ob man
sich zum Beispiel Entlastung jetzt
weiter vornimmt auch als Bundesregierung
sind immer auch ein Ausdruck von
Misstrauen und ich kann das ehrlich
gesagt verstehen wann haben wir das
zweite Entlastungspaket mit den 300 Euro
beschlossen wann haben ein paar Leute
300 Euro dann so oder so bekommen ich
glaube bei mir sind sie zum ersten
Oktober eingetrudelt jetzt reden wir
über den gaspreisdeckel den es viel
früher hätte geben müssen jetzt warten
wir weitere Monate ab und wenn mich
jetzt meine Freunde fragen Sarah was bei
mir jetzt eigentlich mit dem Winter wie
werde ich jetzt eigentlich im Winter
unterstützt dann muss ich immer
Antworten erstmal nicht sehr viele
Studierende fragen sich wie Sie diese
200 Euro am Ende bekommen ein paar Witze
darüber dass dann am Eingang der Uni
jemand steht und jedem noch mal 200 in
die Hand gibt und so regelt man das
Miteinander das schafft natürlich super
viel Unsicherheit und es ist ja auch
nicht so als würde sich kein Protest
formieren und das geht es nicht die
Unsicherheit die sich auch irgendwo
zusammenfindet ist es glaube ich sehr
gut und sehr wichtig zum Beispiel nicht
nur wenn wir darüber reden lassen dass
alle auf sich sitzen oder erwarten alle
nur etwas von dem Staat würde ich auch
immer deswegen nein sagen weil wir jetzt
im Herbst und wintertarifverhandlung
haben werden wo zum Beispiel wer die mit
10,5% reingeht und sagt wir wollen also
nun Preisspirale sowieso nicht ganz
richtig und genau deswegen wollen wir
jetzt dass unsere Löhne steigen da geht
es gar nicht um staatliche Hilfen und
ich glaube genau das zu unterstützen ist
total wichtig es ist jetzt am Wochenende
zum Beispiel sind Demos von ver.di dem
paritätischen auf der Straße und ich
glaube es ist auch richtig gerade den
Unmut auf die Straße zu bringen und wenn
die Links natürlich dann was mich total
fertig macht die Wahlergebnisse in
Niedersachsen klar kann ich mich darüber
freuen dass eine grüne Partei dazu
gewonnen hat aber das sind im
Landesverband wo die AFD quasi non
existent komplett zerstritten ist in dem
plötzlichen Anschub in einem Westland
die AFD sich fast verdoppelt das sollte
uns allen zu denken geben und da hat die
Politik der letzten Monate nicht
wirklich viel Positives zu beigetragen
solchen Initiativen sei es jetzt genug
ist genug oder sei es auch die Demos am
Samstag so und das wäre der Slogan den
sie ja dann im Grunde gegen ihre eigene
Regierung richten genug ist genug weil
sie erstens finden
dass wenn diesen energieabschlag der
Investmentbanker genauso bekommt wie der
Rentner ist das eigentlich ungerecht was
würden Sie noch sagen außer das Argument
das ist einfach alles zu lange dauert
naja also ich glaube in der jetzigen
Situation glaube ich muss es schon darum
gehen dass wir nicht alles mit der
Gießkanne machen ich selbst bin glaube
ich auch eine Verfechterin von
Schnelligkeit an in der Situation und
ich glaube schon dass es das größte
Problem ist dass wir gerade haben und
dass vieles auch noch nicht ganz
absehbar ist wenn wir uns zum Beispiel
die anschauen die eigentlich am
härtesten getroffen sind dann spiegeln
sich deren Belastungen also wir haben ja
auch wir bezahlen ja auch viel für
Butter und Gurke nicht nur für die
Heizkostenabrechnung das spiegelt sich
gerade eigentlich noch nirgendwo wieder
wenn die indexmieten steigen also die
Mieten die an die Inflation gekoppelt
sind dann wünsche ich uns allen guten
Tag weil das sind zehn Prozent
Mietsteigerungen die sollten in jedem
Fall ausgesetzt werden unserer Meinung
nach natürlich in angespannten lagen
sowieso die Mieten gedeckelt werden in
so einer Situation belastet den Haushalt
an der Stelle auch nicht ist vielleicht
auch verträglich für die FDP in so einer
Situation ja verstehe ich dass sie das
anders sehen da haben wir glaube ich
unterschiedliche Meinung aber ich glaube
da sind noch verschiedene Maßnahmen in
der Situation drin und ich glaube auch
dass wir weiter im nächsten Jahr über
ent bisschen reden werden das auch bei
der gaspreisbremse das ist total wichtig
dass sie kommt das sind immer noch sehr
sehr hohe Preise und es werden immer
noch nicht alle gut durchkommen und
deswegen finde ich es auch schön dass
die 200 Milliarden jetzt durch den neuen
Taschenspieler Trick wieder da sind aber
eigentlich führt nichts an der
Aussetzung der Schuldenbremse 2023
vorbei und ich finde es langsam auch ein
bisschen unehrlich wieder mit umgegangen
wird und es kann sein ich bin mir
ziemlich sicher dass wir ein
Entlastungspaket 4 irgendwann haben
werden und braucht es auch richtig das
zu machen denn immer wieder zu sagen man
kann sich aus einer Krise raus sparen
jetzt ist der Begriff Kaufkraft schon
oft genug gefallen wenn die Leute halt
kein Geld in der Tasche haben dann
werden sie auch nichts kaufen in der
Situation und dann sind wir bei Frau
Bobrowski und wollen wissen warum es
eigentlich nur knapp 300 Milliarden sind
noch mal die Frage bei Corona hat der
Staat insgesamt 600 Milliarden
rausgegeben bei der Finanzkrise 500
Milliarden wir haben jetzt verstanden
und übrigens auch in einer Sendung zuvor
schon verstanden dass von diesen 200
Milliarden Doppel Wumms ja ganz viel
anderes auch bezahlt werden sollen hier
gerade schon genannt die Gasversorger
liquiditätshelfen und so weiter wird das
reichen werden wir nicht wirklich
eigentlich sehr viel mehr Geld brauchen
wenn wir sogar noch eine Energiewende
schaffen genau das wollte ich gerade
sagen also viel Geld wird ja gebraucht
um was rauskommen angesprochen hat auch
die die Transformation der Wirtschaft
also diese
Modernisierung Umstellung auf
erneuerbare Energien grüne Wasserstoff
und so weiter das alles wahnsinnig teuer
das können die Unternehmen häufig so
weit ich das verstanden habe nicht
alleine stemmen das heißt sie brauchen
Hilfen zumindest Absicherung vom Staat
das kommt alles noch dazu ja und dann
fehlt es Entlastungspaket man man wird
es sehen das ist hoffentlich dann nur um
das noch mal klarzustellen das geht mir
um die Zielgerichtetheit es geht mir
nicht darum dass man natürlich muss man
entlasten aber diese 300 Euro die über
das ganze Land ausgeschüttet wurden dass
das sagen jetzt glaube ich auch
mittlerweile sind sich da alle einig
dass es keine gute Idee war man muss der
Fairness halt halber vielleicht sagen
dass es immer dann wenn es schnell gehen
muss dann macht man es einfach für alle
gleich also ungerechte Lösungen gehen
halt schnell und sobald sie sozusagen
detailliert und zielgerichtet sind sind
sie kompliziert und das dauert und wir
haben natürlich hier man möchte
einerseits die Erwartungen ja und man
hat natürlich hier sozusagen zwei Dinge
die gleichzeitig erfüllt werden sollen
und dass die widersprechen sich im
Grunde also zielgerichtet hat und
Schnelligkeit so dass vielleicht mal der
der Gerechtigkeit halber ja so und dann
sind wir bei der Frage die die Frau
Heinrich aufgeworfen hat
Schuldenbremse oder weitere sogenannte
Sondervermögen oder Vermögen die in
Wahrheit natürlich gar keine Vermögen
sind wo man dann wenn man diese
Grundsätze von haushaltswahrheit und
Haushalts Klarheit heißt das glaube ich
ja also da das ist das was der im Grunde
genommen dass das klar darüber herrschen
soll was welches Geld haben wir und
welches Geld geben wir aus so da kommt
man ehrlich gesagt ich glaube wir sind
schon an der Grenze dessen was da noch
vertretbar ist und da ist dann die Frage
wie man sich ehrlich gemacht so mit dem
richtigen Zeitpunkt also bei aller
Wichtigkeit der Diskussion über schnelle
Entlastungen verstehen Sie mich nicht
falsch ich halte es wirklich für richtig
schnell zu helfen aber wir kommen nicht
weiter wenn wir nicht die
Langfristperspektive mal aufmachen und
sagen was ist denn das der neue
Normalzustand denn wenn wir den nicht
erreichen und mit dem nicht umgehen
können dann können wir ja für ja
dreistellige Milliardenbeträge verteilen
damit nur Schulden erhöhen aber ich habe
gelernt dass man Schulden irgendwann
auch wieder bezahlen muss das heißt die
Frage ist ja wirklich was ist denn
dieser neue Normalzustand jetzt lobe ich
ein bisschen die gaskommission diese
sieben Cent die identisch sind den 12
nämlich nur in der Frage wie misst du
sie denn wir haben uns getraut
anzunehmen was wird denn der Gaspreis
sein wenn all diese Zuckungen all diese
Veränderungen vorbei sind was ist denn
das neue normal das kann man sagen ihr
seid ja wahnsinnig dass ihr euch das
traut aber ohne eine Perspektive
glaube ich
84 Millionen Menschen oder 60 Millionen
davon die das Reflektieren schwer davon
zu überzeugen wie geht denn das mal
weiter aber auch hunderttausend
Unternehmen in Deutschland schwer davon
zu überzeugen was ist denn die
Zukunftsperspektive durch schwierige
Krisen durchzutauchen auch mal den
Hintern zusammenzuklemmen das schaffen
viele Leute aber wenn keine Perspektive
da ist abermalen sie mal dieses neue
normal was ist das neue normal mit dem
wir uns dann alle anfreunden müssen dazu
gehört auch also ich zitiere das nur
noch mal korrekterweise dass unser
Bundeswirtschaftsminister sagt Teile der
Industrie werden wahrscheinlich weggehen
aus diesem Land wir werden also das ist
ja auch ein Bestandteil an Kaufkraft zu
verlieren an Wertschöpfung zu verlieren
ist das das neue normal oder wollen wir
das noch verhindern das wird schwer
grundsätzlich zu verhindern sein jetzt
nehme ich mal die 7 Cent Nettopreis
Bezugskosten für Gas als Energieträger
und natürlich muss ich jeder Betrieb in
jeder Branche jetzt überlegen wie komme
ich mit 7 Cent pro Kilowattstunde aus
und es wird welche geben die sagen dann
geht es in Deutschland nicht mehr und
dann müssen wir dafür Lösungen suchen
wer kann jetzt herausformen
Investitionen die eigentlich gedacht
waren und notwendig sind um diese
Energiewende zu schaffen 40 Prozent wir
haben eine Umfrage gemacht ich habe das
hinlänglich erzählt wir wollten raus aus
diesen anekdotischen hat mir einer
erzählen genau
von den 600 Mittelständlern die
geantwortet haben 40 Prozent sagen in
der aktuellen Unsicherheit können wir
uns uns nicht leisten die Investitionen
zu machen die wir inhaltlich schon
geplant und das heißt auch sie glauben
dass das wieder einzuholen ist und dass
es wichtig ist und dass das unsere
Zukunft ist strebt die Wirtschaft
Deutschlands denn weiter danach CO2-frei
zu werden absolut dazu stehen wir das
haben wir immer gesagt aber wir müssen
dazu jetzt auch einen ganz konkreten
machen gesagt gesellschaftlich es geht
nicht darum nur Ziele zu wiederholen
oder sie Schaffer zu stellen die werden
alle Maden
schaffen wir bis 2030 Fracking atomkohle
dieses ganze dreckige Zeug tatsächlich
zu ersetzen oder ist es eine Illusion
wer macht was bis wann wer baut's wer
plants wer finanziert und wer betreibts
und ja auch für welchen Profit weil
Unternehmen arbeiten nur dann wenn sie
damit Geld verdienen diese Hausaufgabe
muss man dringend und schnell machen
vorher ist jede Diskussion über Zieljahr
Cocolores wir stehen dazu wir wollen die
2045 schaffen wir haben Zwischenziel bis
2030 das wird unheimlich anstrengend und
wird mit jedem zu warten anstrengender
aber nochmal wenn man es nicht
runterbrechen und ganz klar sagen wer
bauten das jetzt wer sind denn die
Firmen die es bauen wer hat denn die
Kapazität dazu wer finanziert denn wer
finanziert denn die
backupkraftwerke die uns am
Oktoberabend wo weder Solar noch Wind
und hilft trotzdem dafür sorgt dass hier
die Scheinwerfer gehen all diese Dinge
müssen wir jetzt durchdiskutieren wie
man das in dem Unternehmen auch machen
würde wie das der Sportverein machen
würde der neue Sportheimbau was machen
wir jetzt ganz genau wir haben jetzt
leider nicht mehr viel Zeit aber fragen
Herrn felbermaier ganz schnell noch mal
danach ob das tatsächlich beides noch
schaffbar ist wir wollen eine
industrielle Revolution Nummer 2 die nur
eben ohne die Dampfmaschine funktioniert
sondern uns eine Energie und eine
Wirtschaft besorgen soll die ohne
hässliche Emissionen ist ist das noch zu
schaffen ja das ist zu schaffen und der
Grund liegt in der Tatsache dass die
Neuwahlen Energien sehr günstig Strom
produzieren können nicht wir müssen sie
wir müssen die großen
investitionsanstrengungen auf die auf
den Boden bringen übrigens nicht nur in
Deutschland wenn Deutschland das macht
und Europa nicht mitgeht ist überhaupt
nichts gerettet das muss ein
europäischer Kraftakt werden und
eigentlich auch darüber hinaus weil wir
sehr viel günstiger Strom und saubere
Energie gewinnen können in den Ländern
wo der Wind häufig geht natürlich auch
die hässliche Seite Abschlussfrage
vielleicht an beide Politiker wir müssen
auch offensichtlich das schlägt die
Industrie vor über sowas wie Fracking in
Deutschland nachdenken franking gibt es
in Niedersachsen das wünscht sich die
SPD wünscht sich die Ampel dass wir in
Erwägung ziehen um eben unabhängiger zu
werden von unseren
Energieimporten Felbermayer hat eben
gesagt was günstig ist es sind
erneuerbare Energien die stehen übrigens
auch kurzfristiger zur Verfügung als
etwas was mit Planung und Durchführung
und Beteiligungsverfahren irgendwann in
drei oder vier Jahren zur Verfügung
steht und uns jetzt gar nicht hilft ich
bin dafür dass wir uns auf das
Fokussieren was jetzt wirklich klappt
und das wird dafür auch das Geld
einsetzen denn das sehe ich anders als
Frau dubrowski ist nicht die Frage wie
viel wir im Moment ausgeben sondern ob
wir es für den Substanzerhalt in
Deutschland aussetzen wir können nur
etwas wenn sie haben gefragt ob wir uns
das dann eigentlich leisten können oder
ja nicht zu viel wird am Ende und ich
habe es wichtig dass wir uns das leisten
und das der alte Fehler der
Schuldenbremsen Diskussion das nämlich
nur geguckt wird wie viel wird
ausgegeben aber nicht wofür wird
eigentlich ausgegeben uns muss es darum
gehen jetzt alles zu mobilisieren um den
industriellen Kern und alles was ihn
trägt zu sichern mit allem was dazu
weil es kann sich nur eine Wirtschaft
transformieren die noch am Leben ist
eine Raupe die tot ist wird nicht mehr
zum Schmetterling werden und genau darum
geht es jetzt in unserer Volkswirtschaft
am Ende so und dann die Frage auch an
die CDU und nach Niedersachsen
da gibt es dieses Fracking Gas dass wir
heben könnten sagen Sie es ist super
wichtig dass wir endlich auch in eigenen
Dimensionen und Ressourcen denken oder
nein es ist super wichtig dass wir in
unserer Energieversorgung unabhängiger
souveräner werden und dass wir vor allem
verlässliche Energieversorgung haben und
wir können auch so viel Wind und Solar
ausbauen in den nächsten drei vier fünf
Jahren bin ich sofort dabei bis die
Speicherkapazitäten da sind und die
kosten übrigens ganz kostenlos ist das
Speichern schon mal gar nicht werden
noch mindestens 10 15 Jahre vergehen das
bezweifelt niemand bis 2030 werden wir
uns entscheiden müssen Gas Kohle oder
Kernkraft als Backup wie man es nennt um
man am Abend wie diesen Strom zu
produzieren und da rate ich uns einfach
nach den Erfahrungen dieses Krieges
dieser Krise und dem Stress in dem wir
gerade sind nicht jetzt schon wieder
überall Tabus aufzubauen sondern
wirklich einfach mal offen Objektiv so
weit es eben geht daran zu gehen und
miteinander täglich 4 manche sagen sogar
sieben Windräder aufstellen in diesem
Land aber das zehn Jahre lang hilft das
alles nichts wir brauchen bis 2030
irgendwas zwischen 20 und 40 Gigawatt
neue Gaskraftwerken da streiten sich die
gelernt sein 20 bis 40 ich sehe im
Moment nicht dass irgendjemand die baut
und wenn die nicht gebaut werden werden
diese Kohlekraftwerke diese Klimakiller
Kohlekraft weiterlaufen müssen und
deswegen und deswegen kann ich uns nur
im Moment investiert das was in den
Brief von Olaf in der richtigen alle
haben geguckt ob die drei Kraftwerke wer
steht drin dass die Bundesregierung
bestellt dass ich Entwickler in
Deutschland Siemens ganz nah nicht darum
kümmern das dauert kein Kraftwerk nur
weil der Scholzen Brief schreibt es
braucht dafür ein kapazitätsmarkt über
den auch schon länger gesprochen wird
wenn das jetzt alles nächstes Jahr kommt
prima wenn bis 2030 diese Gaskraftwerke
nicht gebaut sind wird es mit
Kohleausstieg nichts Ende Punkt aus und
noch mal nach dem Fracking gefragt
Tracking in Niedersachsen sagt die CDU
ja oder nein es gibt an dem Bundestag
eine Expertenbericht der noch mal
Fracking aufarbeitet und wir haben
gerade beantragt morgen Debatte im
Bundestag dass wir uns diesen Bericht
offen ergebnisoffen anschauen ja ich
glaube man muss wirklich aufpassen in
der Situation bei allen Schwierigkeiten
dass wir nicht anfangen das Ende der
nächsten Monate gegen das Ende des
Planeten auszuspielen wenn wir mehr
fossile Energien brauchen dann hat die
Bundesregierung die Frage auch zu
beantworten wie wir das kompensieren
werden da haben verschiedene Minister
mal mehr Lust mal weniger Lust drauf da
gucke ich auf den Verkehrsminister aber
auch in den Energiefragen werden dass
diese Fragen stellen müssen dann ehrlich
gesagt gibt es keine Wirtschaft auf
einem toten Planeten